one
[Music]
2 I
call out to the
ocean my
tears fall into the
sea for the
vows that have been
broken across the
dunes of time
repeatedly like a
night in battered
armor I
Lay My Sword upon the
ground cuz I can't keep fighting these
same
battles more has been lost than has been
found it's
hard to
feel things
changing after all
all been
said and
[Music]
done we
spend our lives
[Music]
rearranging Under the
Sun I walk the same road to work each
Monday
day every
step tears at my
[Music]
heel I sleep not to
dream but to forget on
Sunday the
spoke just turning with the
wheel it's hard hard to feel things
changing after
all been
said and
[Music]
done we
spend our lives
[Music]
rearranging
everything under the sun
[Music]
reaching for the sky feet buried in the
ground looking for some way out of the
circle spinning
around my eyes on the
horizon seeking out the
light but don't let let me be lost
forever in the
[Music]
night cuz it's
hard to
feel things
changing after
all been
said and
done
we
spend our lives
[Music]
rearranging
everything under the
sun Under the
[Music]
Sun you're amazing that was amazing tall
thank you so much
watch